elles se sont rencontrés sur les bancs
du cours florent puis se sont perdus de
vue
elle ne pensait pas que leurs vies
étaient sensiblement les mêmes rebecca
stella et avait la guillou sont deux
jeunes mères qui ont leurs enfants aînés
diabétiques et elle avait donc deux en
deux ans environ
et puis à la crèche m'avait appelé en me
disant didon votre fille ça va pas fort
un objet de lui donner un truc à manger
à 10 heures sinon elle est ko elle a
tout le temps soit fait beaucoup pipier
vous devriez vérifier le diabète quand
même allé faire une prise de sang
bon je vais faire une prise de sang mais
moi en fait je n'arrivais jamais à ce
qu'elles soient agents puisqu'elle
continue à manger la nuit elle avait
besoin de boire beaucoup quand ils m'ont
dit elle est diabétique comme avait là
je me suis dit ah ben ça va on va juste
pas manger de bons becs et et puis après
ils m'ont dit non c'est plus compliqué
que ça on va tout vous expliquer il faut
que vous compreniez il ya beaucoup de
facteurs à prendre en compte
ça vous sachez faire les calculs et de
ce choc que ces deux mamans ont vécu l
saumon servi pour écrire une première
pièce de théâtre appelé les îles
désertes salvatrice pour ces deux mères
un diabète et bien au moins j'ai des
bons becs plein la poche alors écrit on
fait un massacre
on a pu représenter en faire encore une
fois un spectacle ce qu'est notre métier
et en plus on a pu jouer ce spectacle
qui raconte entre histoire devant des
gens dont c'est l'histoire et après
échangé avec un mois et je pense qu
enfin je parle comme pour avec ainsi
j'ai grandi avec la première pièce parle
d'une petite fille léa qui a 9 ans et
qui apprend qu'elle est diabétique
en fait les as-tu les diabétiques tu
sais ce que c'est que le diabète
non pas du tout je vais mourir non bien
tu ne vas pas mourir
on ne fait pas un documentaire sur ce
que c'est que de vivre avec un diabète
de type 1 on s'intéresse au point de vue
de l'enfant
et puis de l'entourage et ça on a
vraiment voulu décliner dans chacune de
nos pièces et celle qui a entre autre
inspiré ses spectacles c'est yael 11 ans
la fille de rebecca des fois yona qui
nous caractérise comme diabétiques et un
diabétique c'est pas tout ce qui me
définit diabétiques
non ces femmes la danse je suis
passionné de sport c'est j'adore
dessiner enfin c'est que des trucs comme
ça j'ai dis pas que ça en moi maintenant
je juge un professionnel pour expliquer
cette maladie mais avant ça m'énervait
et à chaque fois ma mère venait
expliquer et grâce à ce spectacle ça
éviter de revenir en bout comme ça donc
c'est cool et cette première pièce de
théâtre a donné lieu à une deuxième
les éclipses on retrouve les à
adolescentes l'adolescence c'est bon
j'ai même une insuline
le dernier volet de la trilogie drapeau
blanc était terminée juste avant le
confinement l'oea a 18 ans et entre dans
l'âge adulte
ce nouveau volet sera donc à découvrir
prochainement puisque confinement oblige
il n'a pas pu encore être montrées au
public